thank you so much man
i've never been on the street before
i've been on the streets before i stayed
at the shelter yeah and also it wasn't
scarborough homeless where are you from
originally yeah jamaica this is for you
no i'm okay i've already had a coffee
today
this is for you what is it it's for
helping me
what is it
check what's inside
[Music]
500
you've been missing me yes sir thank you
bro
love you bro all right
so the take talk samaritan zachary joins
me now zachary these are incredibly
moving videos i actually spotted them
just uh
by chance and began watching a few of
them and thought what an extraordinary
thing to be doing and the surprise and
the joy
that they brought to the recipients was
really very moving what made you do this
thank you so much um i started making
the videos about a year ago now
it all really stemmed from when i was
depressed and borderline suicidal and
medical school i was studying medicine
at the university of sydney
and it was almost a cry for help at the
time i made a video about depression and
what i was going through um and then it
just took a life of its own over the
last 10 months so it started with
raising mental health awareness to then
unconditional love and kindness and then
i've been able to grow this thing to
almost 12 million followers in 10 months
and someone a few months ago said it'd
be nice if you could monetarily help
these people in which most situations
i've come across it's the people who
have the least want to give the most
um so it was all been community funded
and just
wanting to connect with strangers this
video right here where i'm blindfolded
hugging a stranger is i'm blindfolded
because
i
didn't know how to connect with my
family and friends back home when i was
depressed and suicidal and i found it
much easier to connect the stranger i
hug people because i haven't hugged
someone in two years and i tell
strangers every time i meet them that i
love them because no one told me they
loved me in two years
so a lot of what i do in terms of giving
back or connecting with
individuals on the streets is just
rooted in my lowest times
right i mean it's interesting that
they're getting obviously a lot out of
it but so are you by the sound of it
it's the most fulfilling opportunity to
be a part of that experience in
connecting with that stranger and the
most beautiful thing other than the
interaction hopefully helping that
individual in that moment
is the fact that this video reaches
millions of individuals who either need
to see something like that or then get
inspired to do the same in their own
life to whatever whether it's holding a
door buying a coffee flower asking
someone how they're doing because
sometimes those small things can really
make or break someone's day or life
because we never know what people are
going through right i mean you've had
you've got 8.5 million followers on tick
tock you've had 273
million likes on tick tock millions more
on other platforms could you even
imagine in your wildest dreams when you
started this that you'd end up as this
kind of tick-tock samaritan sensation
absolutely not i made the first video to
find a friend and then continue medical
school so this was never never in my
wildest dreams what i thought i'd be
doing right now and how do you actually
raise the money i know you crowdfunded
but how does that work
so there's a donation link on all my
platforms that runs 24 7. so however
much i'm able to raise within that span
before i make the next video i then
directly have to give 500 away or a
thousand and then even more powerful i
find is when i find a stranger where
that money isn't enough i link gofundme
so we've raised nearly 250 000 in the
past couple months for strangers on top
of the fact of the videos
absolutely incredible well look i found
it very moving your story uh i love what
you do we'd like to just do a little
tiny contribution towards it because
you've been kind enough to come on the
show
so we'd love to just give you a thousand
dollars from peers morgan uncensored the
next time you're out there uh just give
it to whoever you think would deserve
that and that's just our little way of
saying thank you for the interview and
thank you for what you're doing it's an
amazing thing
piers morgan thank you so much for that
that
you have no idea how much that means to
me thank you thank you thank you and for
this opportunity to connect and yeah
thank you so much well thank you zachary
we need more people like you in the
world good luck to you
i love you bye pierce all the best